all right today's draft the all-time
great defensive plays that prompt the
reaction far different than the reaction
that the ten-year-old version of me had
at the time which was to go into the
kitchen and cry on the floor for 20
minutes trivia question Chris speaking
of being on the floor you had two starts
in your career when you were never put
on the floor of a football stadium you
weren't sacked twice in your career you
weren't sect can you name the games Wow
there was two games I wasn't sacked I
can't I don't know if I can name these
two games here's a hint they were in
back-to-back weeks is that help active
okay I'm gonna say I'm gonna say it was
week the last game of the year in 2005
versus the Saints and then the wild-card
game against the Washington Redskins
oh you're incorrect right year but
absolutely wrong although you got one of
the teams right it was regular-season
36:35 win versus Washington and then 32
732 27 win at Atlanta those were the two
games where you weren't sacked so I I
thought you get the birdies one of them
since it only happened twice
yeah why it's it's you don't remember
like I can remember you know you don't
remember sacks that much as a
quarterback you don't you know a lot of
times that's why sacks is overrated you
know sometimes the offensive line or
like feel good a bit we didn't let up
any socks last week and you be like yeah
but I got hit on every drop back pass
during the game so it wasn't that fun
guys I would have rather got sacked two
or three times and then hit like 25 less
time so it's it's one of those things
you kind of block out as a quarterback
altogether alright I get the first pick
and I think the first one that comes to
mind is and I know when we decided to do
this the other day the first one I
thought of was Steve Atwater who will
enter the Hall of Fame this year blowing
up Christian Okoye I think it was a
Monday night game it was just one of
those it stopped Cristiano quai in his
tracks and it stopped anyone who was
watching the game in their trash it
still to this day does not look real and
this isn't this isn't Darren Sproles
this right Nicoya it was a giant
and Stevo out water obviously smaller
than a koi a putting him on his rear end
Chris so for me if there was one pic in
any draft that's the pic that that's a
good one like it really is I can
remember watching that I mean that was a
fun game and you're right
Cristiano koi yay the Nigerian nightmare
right as they called them he was famous
for just absolutely running people over
so we had never seen him go backwards
and steve-o at water one of the greatest
hitters and in NFL history all right I'm
gonna go to one in my early life it was
the first maybe defensive player that a
defensive player that ever made me go oh
alright the 1986 divisional playoff game
Joe Montana and the San Francisco 49ers
come into New York Giants and taken on
LT and the 1986 did this play right here
Jim Burt crushes Joe Montana LT pick six
I think that makes it 28 or 35 to three
and I just remember going oh my gosh
we're gonna kill the 49ers and yeah as
you can see Joe was out on his feet and
I certainly don't like to see that but
you know when you're a Giants and and
you know your dad and team hadn't won a
Super Bowl yet you're gonna do whatever
you got to do to hope your team can win
that was a huge moment I know in my life
my dad's life and everything about it
and I can still remember even at six and
a half years old sitting there watching
that play and the speed that we saw
there from Lawrence Taylor just
incredible almost like they sped up the
video right my dad really seemed you god
I was gonna say my dad would claim that
he saw Lawrence Taylor run of four five
one or four or five flat at 251 pounds
on grass you know on grass which is
supposed to be slower so that just
speaks to what I think you're talking
about the specimen of which is Lawrence
Taylor but think about it how often does
a linebacker have a chance to run like
that in a straight line in a game what
when is that ever going
happen I think that's the only time I've
ever seen a linebacker get the ball down
the field and just fire out of a cannon
with no one around him you just see that
that doesn't hit the football field and
he's one of the ones who had the rear
speed to turn it into a touchdown before
anybody could get in his way
all right I got a lot I can choose from
here I know this the this one and we
talked about him yesterday or at least
we had a clip from a podcast you
contributed to it wasn't a regular
season game it wasn't a playoff game it
wasn't a preseason game it was that
albatross the Pro Bowl which currently
is two-hand touch in full pads the last
time we saw a big hit in the Pro Bowl
and maybe the only time we saw a
ridiculously big hit in the Pro Bowl
came when the late Sean Taylor decided
to make Bryan Mormon he just saw my gosh
Bryan Mormon he knocked him he knocked
him back to California I I totally
forgot about this play but you're right
that might be the last hit in the Pro
Bowl oh that poor punter he thinks he's
going out to Hawaii to collect the check
and get some Sun and he gets derailed by
Sean Taylor and let me tell you Sean
Taylor is scary I mean he was scary I
mean an RI P to him one of the the great
specimens I ever played against but
that's the last guy you want to see he
running at you at full speed holy cow
that was a car wreck
alright good pick by you very creative
I'm gonna go too you know I'm going
somewhere close to home here again I'm
gonna go to the NFC Championship game
Tampa Bay Bucs verse the Philadelphia
Eagles ok the Bucs team if you can
remember can't win in the cold weather
can't get to the Superbowl that great
defense but when Ronde Barber makes the
Pick six and returns at 90 something
yards for a touchdown you know that was
one of those days where you just kept
going man Tampa is not gonna win this
they're not gonna beat Philly Phil he's
still gonna come back you know they can
do
this and then I remember just watching
and like getting out of my seat like oh
my gosh holy cow and of course I didn't
know Ronde Barber at that time would get
to know him the next year but just one
of those moments where you went and
complete shock you thought Donna McNabb
was gonna deliver instead it was Ronde
Barber and that Bucs defense and to me
one of the great defensive plays of all
time
now I had a similar choice in mind and
Ronde Barber was a guy who always made
plays from anywhere on the field he
would you never know if he was gonna
blitz what he was gonna do he was an
incredible x-factor for my defense in
the 2008 NFC AFC excuse me championship
game Troy Polamalu had the interception
return where I mean he was like the
Tasmanian Devil right I'm if once he had
the ball in his hands he was unstoppable
and he didn't run in a straight line he
was all over the place but that's not I
pick my what we'll look at it anyway
it's not my pick let's look at it he
snags the ball and it's the he was the
automat broken fieldrunners a defensive
player I used to joke that they should
make him their kick returner cuz once he
had the ball nobody got here with your
right and so fly and he can make people
miss I mean he definitely had punt
return capabilities Mike you're right
about that we talked about how
quarterbacks have a great uncanny sense
of the relation of themselves in space
to others and that that's I think that's
was was Troy Polamalu was best trait and
he used that when he played defense and
he used it on those occasions when he
got the ball in his hands but my
official pick at least we got to see the
extra mid draft bonus pick this was I
think it was a Thursday night game
Packers Vikings we've talked about this
before Warren Moon was playing
quarterback for Minnesota and and oh we
have talked about it because is the old
it looks good on the whiteboard but when
it's time to actually do it the X's in
the O's don't quite mesh because
somebody in Minnesota thought it would
be a good idea to have Chris Carter try
to block it did not go well for Chris
Carter and it was almost it was almost a
disaster for Warren Moon because he that
was part of thrown into his legs
this is just amazing and it's like well
Reggie white I think was apoplectic
you're gonna try to block me with this
guy and he finally just like the heck
with this get out of here that's amazing
yeah that is totally I mean hey on the
chalkboard look we got him block guys
we're good don't worry about it oh yeah
except that's maybe the greatest
defensive player in the history of the
sport who can throw around three hundred
and thirty pound offense alive and let
alone 220 pound wide receivers the
hesitation from the hesitation from
Reggie White was like I can't believe
they're doing this they're really doing
this and he finally decides that God is
Chris Carter get out of my way you're
very creative today very good I'm very
very no no I actually I actually
prepared I actually prepared you
admitted earlier during a break that you
forgot to prepare that's the defense
preparations go ahead I just go off a
Total Recall I'm with a great NFL
encyclopedia okay all right I'm going to
another one - that's you know yeah not
going to be in the lures of the all-time
great defensive plays but to me is still
a moment where I went oh and it was yeah
a little person with me 1989 John I'm
going back to Denver Mike where we
already saw Steve a letter at water but
this is Gary reasons okay and I can't
remember the runningbacks name Oh him
right Bobbie Humphrey Bobbie Humphrey
from Alabama watch his ear pads fly out
of his helmet and pop into the air in
the snow and you got to watch closely
but you'll see it fall down oh there it
is I saw it over to the right yes is one
of the great collisions there it is
right there - in the history of football
and that was a huge moment the Giants
were fighting for a number one and
number two seed in the NFC that year
ultimately were the number two seed and
we know the Denver Broncos were a very
good football team they went to the
Super Bowl that year and lost to the
49ers but I'll never forget that play
Mike that was a big time hit probably
illegal this day on the edge in the NFL
and you know why outside won't forget
later that night we had some crazy guy
in our town come to our house and try to
chainsaw down our mailbox at like
midnight and I can remember being nine
years old and just being like what the
hell is going on here but that was one
of my favorite defensive plays ever so
another late night visit from lawrence
taylor it turned out you know i thought
about another one that really wasn't
during a play it was when Jack Lambert
threw Cliff Harris to the ground in
Super Bowl talk about this play how
about this one it wasn't in the NFL but
do you remember this one don't you I
think we've had a program before once or
twice or 17 times Chris Sims of
inaudible a bad idea there's Roy ways
and and there's the interception and
there's the touchdown that hurt and let
me just tell you I'm gonna have boy
Williams my Roy Williams on the right
and he's got a lot of space and if he
makes one guy miss it's gonna be a huge
game and that was number one verse
number 2 that place still hurts me and
that was just a great play by their
rules who was probably the best if it's
a player in college football at that
time
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports